so good to see you queen yo you look
beautiful
thank you you do too okay first of all
paris have you explained
to your mother what hunky dory means
for the love of god yes i called her
that
after i was like mom you don't know what
hunky dory means she's like
no i've never heard that before who is
it i was like mom
she just yeah she's never heard that
term before
oh my god i absolutely love her she's
become such a fan favorite like
discovering
red bull her humor her pranks have you
been enjoying watching her on the show
yes she is so hilarious and yeah
watching her i could just see so many
similarities in myself so now i
know where i get it i'm the og but she's
the real og
she's the real og congratulations on
cooking with paris you know a viral
youtube video leading to your very own
series is this something that you
imagined what happened no i never would
have imagined that i would have a
cooking show
but i'm so happy that i do and so happy
that it's on netflix
and it's just been an amazing experience
and
i'm thrilled with how it turned out and
i just can't wait for the world to watch
it
yeah we love seeing uh kim kardashian
taking charge in the kitchen with you
were you impressed by her skills
yes definitely well being a mother of
four she's obviously in the kitchen a
lot with them
and she's telling me about the homemade
pizza that she makes so she's going to
teach me how to make that
when i have kids one day so it was a lot
of fun to be with her in the kitchen
yeah um we love seeing you guys reunite
on tv but how often do you guys reunite
in real life do you guys see each other
all the time
well obviously with the world being shut
down i haven't seen most of my friends
um so whenever we do have time we will
but it's just
it's been hard with the world right now
yeah yeah
um you guys brought so many great
celebrities to the show
um who were you most impressed by
everybody just i had so much fun just
cooking with everyone
the one person i was very impressed with
was sweetie yeah
she knows her way around the kitchen her
mom taught her how to make these shrimp
tacos which we made which were so
delicious
so i definitely learned a lot from her
she's definitely
a better cook than i am
yeah but your cooking show it's it's
realistic like a lot of people don't
know how to
operate in the kitchen and you make it
fun and interesting so we appreciate
that
um if there is a season two which i'm
imagining there will be cooking with
paris
who would be your absolute dream guest
i'm assuming you probably have somebody
on your mind already
uh there's lots of people and ever since
the trailer just dropped this morning
i've had
so many of my friends reach out wanting
to be able to go
so i'm very excited to do a season two
and i think it would be a lot of fun to
be in the kitchen with brittany
or madonna i think that they would be
just so much fun
oh i would love that um you are engaged
and we
love love at et canada so
congratulations
um what has carter brought into your
life
he just is the most amazing man i've
ever met in my life
and yeah just makes me feel so safe and
he's just like my home i love him so
much he's my best friend
best partner in life and i'm just so
excited for our future together
obviously you have so much experience
now in the kitchen since you've been
filming
the show um if i were to come over what
is
one dish you would cook me that would
just blow me away
i think it would have to be my living
lasagna because that
was my specialty and that's how this all
started yeah
so i think that i know that you would
love it it's
so good it's the best lasagna in the
world yes what would you say is your
favorite meal of the day breakfast
i love lucky charms cereal
this french toast that i made that has
lucky charms on it
yeah um yeah and i love breakfast food
awesome thank you for your time paris
it's good to see you again